[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show i
previously praised the decision by CVS
pharmacies to stop selling cigarettes
CVS made this play to get more into the
promotion of human health these minute
clinics that they have where you can get
not only get your flu shots but i think
they also have like nurses on site where
you can do maybe some minor like medical
consultations with them in any case
they're going in the direction of being
more about promoting health and you
can't really promote health and sell
cigarettes and they made the correct
decision to stop selling cigarettes at
this point i think it's been a couple
years CVS health said sunday that it had
agreed to buy Aetna for about 69 billion
dollars in a deal that would be a
gigantic deal because of what it would
do to the nation's health care industry
and this is part of the sort of blurring
of the lines between the separate
elements of the health world now there
are those who might argue that this is a
good thing and then there are others who
argue that vertical integration is
really bad and when you've got a health
insurance company like Aetna controlled
by CVS which is like a retail outlet for
a lot of these health products pharmacy
etc that that really creates
circumstances where CVS health could
manipulate the their acceptance or
relationship with health insurance
companies in a way to try to push people
to Aetna coverage or in other ways kind
of influence and and I guess not that
it's a free market but influence the
freedom of that market I don't know
ultimately what's going to happen here
because this is not there are all sorts
of other transformations taking place in
healthcare right now you've got insurers
hospitals and pharmacy companies that
are working together in different ways
you've got the potential shake-up still
I guess the Republicans want to shake it
up Obamacare you have Congress at a
total impasse about what the path
forward is going to be and medical costs
keep going up because of this vicious
circle
of medical billing and the uninsured who
used the emergency room as primary care
so it's so hard to really gauge what
this would do generally speaking as a
progressive I get concerned about these
mega mergers that that have vertical
integration taking place yeah but I
wonder if that everyday person would see
those negative effects at least directly
because maybe they would just see this
as more convenient say your health
insurer is Aetna and you have a CVS in
town it for the average person it just
seems to be one in the same right you go
and you have this one place to stop and
you get all your stuff done well that's
exactly the line that Aetna and CVS are
pushing which is hey listen Aetna is
just an insurer but if Aetna and CVS
health are the same companies Aetna
could actually be at CVS you could have
people that work with the insurance
company at CVS which would just make
maybe insurance issues that come up with
prescriptions much more easier much much
easier to resolve right on the spot I
don't know I mean I mean if your
employer is that in a coverage right and
you don't have a CVS in the area that
creates issues if they're you were in
fewer places where you can go to get
health insurance and to get your
prescriptions because of all these
mergers that's a bad thing too that's
the main counter argument which is that
you're going to find choices limited
potentially because Aetna might force
people with their insurance to go only
to CVS for much of their care and there
might not be a CVS there and of course
anytime you have limited choices you
don't really have market power in terms
of negotiating on prices so it's not a
unique concern to this merger Time
Warner AT&T merger all these mergers
basically surface the exact same
concerns I was gonna say I think this is
where the rubber meets the road because
if you remember the Trump Justice
Department is suing to block the AT&T
Time Warner merger I did and we had
suspicions that maybe had to do with
Trump's to stain over CNN correct so if
they're going to try to block that
merger and they just leave this one
alone
that's suspect to me oh no no this is a
completely different thing Pat you need
to understand that this merger is fine
it's the other one that's actually the
problem that we need to worry about
you've convinced me many girls get
married before the age of 18
in Ethiopia and the legal age of
marriage is actually 18 there are some
of these some nations around the world
don't have an 18 year old marriage age
limit I don't know what to call it age
it is it even slightly limit though what
it would be like requirement yeah
requirement minimum age required for
marriage a lot of places don't even have
an eighteen-year-old
requirement but a lot of the ones that
do just don't enforce it and the problem
is that there is a big incentive for
families to marry off their daughters
because very often there are sort of
financial arrangements that are put in
place or if you're a struggling family
in for example Ethiopia and you have a
thirteen-year-old daughter and if you
marry off the thirteen-year-old daughter
it might come with some financial
benefit you were going to receive you
were going to be incentivized to marry
your daughter off even though she's only
13 years old so what a region and North
northern Ethiopia is doing is it is
rewarding not marrying off your daughter
when you have girls in your family
between ages I believe it's 10 and 18 if
the family keeps the girls unmarried and
in school right it has to be both
unmarried and in school they will be
rewarded with a goat a sheep or a pair
of chickens which in this region is
actually a really important thing that
allows you to feed your family yeah and
they're actually seeing that the
chickens are often the best option in
this area in Ethiopia the eggs because
the eggs yeah the school girls can sell
eggs in exchange for supplies
whereas I guess it's typical for men to
take care of the goats so that's another
directly help them as much chickens are
the way to go here so this does appear
to be making a difference and it's not
just the chickens but yes pat is right
that the chickens having a
disproportionately positive impact and
if you so you have to participate in
this program it's not you need to make
yourself known as hey we have a daughter
of the age that is eligible and we want
to participate and of the people that
are participating those who those who
are participating are 90 percent less
likely to marry off their young girls
than those in nearby communities that
are not participating so financial
incentive I mean it's not not a shock
that this is working and they've
actually tried things like this
there were similar but sometimes they
would just give them money which didn't
work out so well because that could just
raise the dowry because I guess you know
the family is then more negotiating
power indeed they already have some
money in their bank accounts so they can
take more for their child it didn't
really help as much as animals are
that's interesting right so if you have
no money in your bank account you might
be willing to accept $100 dowry for
marrying off your daughter but if you
already have a hundred bucks you might
be able to say hey you know what we're
not that desperate we're gonna hold out
for five hundred dollars we are don't
counterproductive in that way that's
interesting or at least not helpful the
UM the basic income experiments in
African villages have actually worked
quite well but of course the point there
is not to prevent child marriage it's a
completely different thing that's being
tested and I've been following some of
those initiatives but as far as this
idea of preventing the marrying off of
young girls similar programs have been
launched in Tanzania and Burkina Faso
and tens of thousands of girls are being
enrolled in these programs and hey
listen tailored solutions for the
problems that you have maybe in those
countries goats would be more helpful
than chickens goats whoo yeah it's
possible but you can get milk from the
goat yeah but like I I think it's just
because men tend to tend to the goats
interesting yeah yeah you know obviously
goats don't lay eggs but what else can
you get from the goat I mean other than
the meat just the UH just the milk and
you can make goat before you want from
this guy yeah I know that's true yeah
absolutely
now if you were in assert its in
situations like that would you still be
vegan probably not no I mean if it
wasn't practical for me to be vegan yeah
if I had to survive and I had limited
resources yep
you gotta do what you got to do hey
that's uh that's the story of the of
Homo sapiens isn't it but I live like
walking distance to a grocery store so
I'm okay
yep plenty of quinoa and lentils and and
fortunately right now there's not a run
on lentils that would be a big deal
actually that would be a huge huge
problem Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos had a
two-day period during which he was the
world's only centi billionaire meaning
that he had over 1 did I say yeah
billions a millionaire he had over 100
billion dollars in net worth and that
happened because on cyber monday Amazon
did so well that
chairs of Amazon went up in value and he
was worth over a hundred billion dollars
but then he lost 2.2 billion
what's a couple billion between friends
he lost a couple billion dollars in net
worth when Amazon stock dropped and he
went back to being worth only 98 billion
dollars poor guy
yeah it's not even clear that we can
really wrap our heads around how much
money that is yeah no I was thinking
about this so like imagine having a
hundred thousand dollars in one's right
spread throughout the room yeah a
hundred thousand dollars that's a lot of
money break about that in one's yep
would fill the whole room now he has a
million dollars for every single one of
those $1 bills correct think about that
uh you think he even has a grasp of how
much money he has like what is it and
again a lot of this is tied up in Amazon
stock so he doesn't really have it until
he sells the stock which would drop the
value if Jeff Bezos starts you know very
quickly divesting from from his own
company stock but look what does it even
mean to him do you think his conception
of it could not possibly be different
between having 50 billion and a hundred
billion right I mean after the first
billion what can you really do with that
money like we got the largest house you
can buy maybe it's worth a hundred
million dollars yeah you get a few nice
cars I mean it gets to a point where you
can't really get anything good out of
that that money that you have unless you
you know set up charitable organizations
well that is the marginal utility of
money and there are there is a camp that
says that the marginal utility of money
is always one-to-one that if you've got
a billion dollars and you get one more
dollar that the utility of that
additional dollar is identical to
someone who has $100 and gets one more
dollar I tend to reject that I think
that mark the marginal utility of money
diminishes as you accrue more and more
money it just seems like basic
percentages to me right I mean I'm no
well economics expert myself not on a
percentage basis that yeah on a dollar
by dollar basis right they're arguing
they're arguing the percentage approach
oh I see if you take a percentage
approach then you would say no it's
obvious if you have net worth increases
by 1% versus by point zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero a little obvious
then right it kind of makes it obvious
that that's gonna have a different level
of level of utility second most richest
what do you think it is right now yes
Bill Gates
he's like 89 billion oh I thought that
he went back and forth with Carlos Slim
the Mexico you can throw in Warren
Buffett Warren Buffett as well yeah I've
seen you know expectations predictions
that per trillion those could become the
first trillionaire just based on the
rate that his money is growing yeah
maybe so how old the guy is he like
early 50s or late fees I mean that's who
old you know he's middle-aged guy are
you into reading about people like Jeff
Bezos and Steve Jobs like I have some
friends who are obsessed with with
reading other there I don't know if it's
biographies autobiographies who knows
what they've even written I just am NOT
interested in reading those non-fiction
books no not not so much myself I don't
know it seems like a lot of focus on one
person like if there was a book about
ten self-made billionaires okay I would
read that you would yeah okay you read
uh like by political biographies like I
have a friend who read the LBJ right
president how the outer pages or
something like that I just can't do it I
can't do it yeah that's a little much a
little much about about any one person I
think I think it's more of a genre thing
for me I've just never been into
biography Wow
well I don't know what to tell you you'd
start with maybe john d rockefeller
richest person of all time arguably at
the time inflation adjusted or something
right yeah if you uh if you look at this
net worth now I think it would be worth
like a hundred and fifty billion dollars
oh is that true yeah I didn't realize
that even still with Bezos he still
would have was richer at the time
Standard Oil
what about Pablo Escobar I don't know
cuz at one point that highly his
business was bringing in like a hundred
million dollars a month or something
absolutely an utterly insane but maybe
in in terms of so then let say so
adverse so then it would take what a
thousand months for him to accumulate a
hundred billion dollars and that's
assuming all that money goes to him
yeah and that's like eighty five years
so is that he didn't last that long
before the CIA got through the I gotcha
yeah alright that's it for today's bonus
show we'll be back tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]